[Music]
an epic tale of male friendship against
the backdrop of the italian alps the
eight mountains is a stunning film
co-directed by belgian charlotte
vandanish
[Music]
it spans decades and continents and is
one of the 21 films competing for the
palm door prize
we approach it as a love story because
friendship is love
and
family is important
mother father your ancestors also can
you escape
where you come from can you do it
differently what's your destiny can you
escape your destiny vandamish
co-directed with her husband felix van
gronigen and spoke about what she
learned from the process be able to say
no to people when it's necessary and to
invite them in and be generous when
there's a time for it but just to remain
really focused
because that's the heart of what you're
doing and
and yeah often filmmaking is just a lot
of things at the same time so
and go
in the history of cannes only two women
have won the palmdale prize for best
director and though protests forced the
festival to sign a gender parity pledge
in 2018 this is a problem not just for
the festival but for the film industry
at large
this year only 25 of the films submitted
for consideration were directed by women
still a record for can
rodeo is a french film about a girl
breaking into a male-dominated world set
in the suburbs of bordeaux it follows a
group of working-class kids pursuing
their passion for illegal dirt bike
racing
first-time director lola quivron spent
four years investigating the motocross
scene she says she wanted to create a
character we rarely see on screen
she's just too impolite to to say
hello i'm julie how are you no no no
she's like
wow breaking the world and get into the
group
i like violent a
female character
female directors like quiveron and van
der meesch are offering fresh voices in
cinema their films were snapped up even
before being screened in cannes proving
the audience appetite is already there
charlie angela al jazeera can